في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض انتهت عمليه
الفصل التوام السيامي اليمني سلمان وعبد
الله وعمرهما اربعه اشهر وذلك في مستشفى
الملك عبد الله التخصصي للاطفال بمدينه
الملك عبد العزيز الطبيه هذا وشارك في
العمليه خمسه وثلاثون طبيبا وكادرا فنيا
وطبيا كما تم اجراء العمليه على سبع مراحل
من مستشفى الملك عبدالله التخصصي بوزاره
الحرس الوطني ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
نواف عزيز نواف مساء الخير يعطيك العافيه
يا نواف انت موجود ومواكب لهذه العمليه
منذ الصباح بمراحلها السبعه نريد ان تجمل
وتلخص لنا ما الذي حدث منذ الصباح حتى
الان في هذه العمليه وهي انتهت طبعا قبل
ساعات
بالتاكيد نايف قبل دقائق وصل التوام
السيامي اليمني سلمان وعبد الله الى قسم
التنوين في العنايه المركزه قبل دقائق فقط
انتقلوا من غرفه العمليات الى هذا القسم
بعد نجاح العمليه نشاهد من خلفي الان
التوام
يتواجد في هذه الغرفه بجانبه ايضا
الطفل الاخر بحضور من العائله وبتواجد
ايضا من الدكتور عبد الله الربيعه قائد
الفريق الطبي اذا كان الدكتور يستطيع
التحدث معنا وهو يشرف على حاله التوام
السيامي بعد الانتقال الى العنايه المركزه
اهلا وسهلا دكتور ماذا بعد العمليه كم
سيبقى الطفلين في
القسم التنوين بالعنايه المركزه وكيف
ستتابعون ذلك اولا مرحبا بكم بمشاهدين
الكرام
العربيه والحمد لله رب العالمين ان هذه
العمليه تكللت بالنجاح وفي وقت قياسي
واشكر من دعم وتابع ووجه بهذه العمليه
خادم الحرم الشريفين وولي عهد الامين حفظه
الله كذلك اشكر زملائي وزميلاتي اعضاء
الفريق الطبي
35 من الاستشاريين والاخصائيين والكوادر
التمريضيه والفنيه تعمل معنا ووجه لهم
كلمه شكر وتقدير طبعا العمليه كما شاهدتم
وتسمعون سياح سلمان خلفي ونفس الشيء عبد
الله هنالك انجاز اخر انه من النادر ان
نستطيع رفع الانابيب وافاقه الاطفال في
التوائم السياميه الحمد لله اليوم هذا
انجاز اخر ان سلمان افاق بعد اكتمال
العمليه وعبد الله افاق بعد اكتمال
العمليه والان هو ربما يطلب بعض المهدئات
من الالم او الرضاعه بالنسبه
55 فصل للتوائم بنجاح لليمن ثمان حالات
اليوم هذه هي الثامنه بالنسبه لسلمان وعبد
الله من محافظه الجوف ولكن اذا نظرنا
لبقيه التوائم ياتون من جميع المحافظات
صعد الصنعه تعز عدن وحضرموت وهذا يؤكد ان
العمل الانساني السعودي عمل شفاف عمل
محايد لا يرتبط باي اجنده لا يرتبط
جغرافيه سياسيه عسكريه انما هدف المملكه
العربيه السعوديه رفع معاناه الانسان
اينما كان نعم الدكتور مجريات العمليه
لاحظنا ان العمليه مرت بساعات اقل من
المعتاد في العمليات الاخرى لفصل التوام
كيف كانت المجريات هل كانت العمليه سهله
لم تواجه صعوبات
كل عمليه فيها تحدياتها وصعوباتها لكن يجب
ان يعلم الجميع ان هنالك فريق طبي لديه
خبره تزيد عن
سنه هذا الفريق الطبي اللي مهما شكرتهم
انا اكون مقصر وهذه الخبره
تعكس كيفيه التعامل مع التحديات والصعوبات
مثل ما حدث اليوم هنالك تحديات اشتراك في
الامعاء في المثانه البوليه بين الامعاء
والمثانه البوليه في الجهاز التناسلي ولكن
استطاع الفريق ان يتعامل معها ويقصر وقت
العمليه والتوام يفيق وهو في غرفه
العمليات انا اعتقد هذا ليس سهوله عمليه
وانها خبره فريق خبره وطن
ودعم من القياده للانسان كل الشكر لك
الدكتور عبد الله الربيعه قائد الفريق
الطبي الذي اجرى عمليه فصل التوام السيامي
اليمني كما ذكر الدكتور عبد الله نايف بان
هناك متابعه مستمره عمليات تجميل وان كانت
بسيطه ولكن هناك متابعه مستمره لحاله
التوام السيامي اليمني سلمان وعب الحمد
لله على سلامتهم شكرا جزيلا لك ولضيفك
الكريم من مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي
بوزاره الحرس الوطني مراسل العربيه